[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to week three of
the protest league my name is Caleb
Dundee I'm all I'm joined as always by
dorsa Derrick Shani and today we're
gonna be going over the match between
the st. Louis Archbishop's and the
Chicago winds door so what's our what's
our roster looking like um pretty strong
eye stronger than I thought yeah I kinda
expected Bobby and Wesley to not play
due to Tata Steel but right well so yeah
a couple of our players of course
playing in the Tata Steel Masters
Tournament Fabiano I think still in the
lead in that tournament although I
didn't check back in I think I think
it's not the sole leader it's thank you
so for the moment maybe but yeah so Fabi
and Wesley both playing for us from the
Tata Steel masters tournament as well as
leni a Dominguez will be our board too
and Benjamin Bach will be rounding out
our roster on on board for but so that's
yeah it's it's definitely not the
easiest pairings of the world though
we're up against a very strong Chicago
win team which features Ray Robson
iliyan is Nick let's see Lazzaro bruise
on Bautista and uni Eskie Quesada Perez
and so that's actually two of the
strongest Cuban players it was it I
think so I think that was the quick
fixes hint but yeah shut up that but
yeah I think well the thing is even
though we playfully called them the
Webster at Chicago Webster's but I mean
that means guys through though yeah so a
lot of Webster players though that X
Webster players playing in Chicago win
team so it's interesting to see how they
uh oh they're all working together for
under a new name but largely the same
team I think yes of course the Webster
windmills last year one of the toughest
contenders
we'll see how they do here today and I
think dorsa the games are actually
getting underway so maybe if we can pull
up the board yeah all the way on the
left I think yeah we have three of them
have started and yes so three games
underway and then I think the fourth one
isn't quite going just yet but we do
have Fabiano's game here against yeah
Fabia's playing Ingrid's
a bow an early e5 from Fabi so yeah it
was a interesting choice of opening well
I mean the thing with this offense is I
feel like in this specific situation
it's um it's very nice because it takes
the center on everything but this d5
hole if White's had a knight on c3 and
an icon III and had this domination of
d5 then this would have really scared me
but I think in this specific situation
shortly after could be followed with d5
from black side right and yeah it starts
to look more like an e4 e5 opening then
yeah very nice Lopez yeah yeah black
simply just plays d6 keeping the center
closed for the moment Bishop e6 might be
coming soon and then you see in the
Rhoyne Lopez sometimes like the knight
on c6 has to move out of the way for
black to play c5 but no black is I'm
also a big fan of this G 66 of stuff in
real ofays so it's it looks like a very
good through Lopez honestly okay so
definitely a decent position for Fabi
yeah some of these other games let's
take a look at linear so Lenny a is up
against a bruise on Batista and it looks
to be what in exchange French or
something something that nature
no just e45 but all the possible weird
brilliant open Roy
so far everything is normal yeah this
one
Oh theory all theories this one doesn't
look too dangerous to my eyes yeah I
think this is gonna be a dead drop
I mean um theoretically right words
which is probably a favorable result for
Batista actually but so we'll see if
Dominguez can can try and create some
complications you know and games are
never never easy especially madness um
let's take a look at so this this game
yes so this is actually our board three
Wesley so up against board two for
Chicago iliyan is Nick but of course
since our top three boards are so strong
we are still largely favored in this man
ship as well then um couldn't you don't
think I've leaked one last two games yes
so Liam Lee is is the notable missing
player from our roster today of course
our absolute strongest roster it has him
on board for even though he's well over
27 years but today no Liam Lee instead
we have Benjamin Bach on board for and
we could actually check up on how he's
doing yeah well he they just started the
little later so I wanted to see how the
other boards were doing but yeah it
looks like a perfectly reasonable
opening position here he has against Ray
Robson
yeah in our team ago list of both
positions but yeah okay so what why do
you call him why do you call them that
is he known for for this type of yeah
from what I know he he likes to know a
lot about theory right so he's always
checking up and doing his best to come
up with ideas and she stuff and you
actually say after Eve for the the
center is kind of blowing up what's yeah
the stuff was like his style
so you're saying you expect that he
knows exactly what's going on here this
is something I am he's looked at this is
oh if he starts thinking for more than
like 20 seconds that's where I would be
like oops his prep ism either like gone
valid anymore maybe in this age six move
is is the move that does it let's hope
not I mean it thinks there's nothing
that's special I mean it's kind of like
feels like one of the only moves cuz it
was between probably Knight f6 and h6
but Knight f6 there's Bishop g5 right so
yeah maybe h6 is somebody forced to move
back yeah but so what could might do
here now to try to keep the pressure up
it looks like one of those positions
where even if the structure is larger
the same that the white pieces are kind
of just a little bit more active things
like rook d1 might be coming to put some
pressure along all these pieces lined up
on the D file including the black Queen
I was thinking about maybe defy even de5
and then after Knight takes e5 I think I
think rookie rook d1 might be a good
move there as well because like ideally
I would want to have this bishop on c1
and c3 and that's what be a monster but
I don't really see that happening
anytime soon
um yeah interesting so this one also
doesn't look like it well it's
definitely not dangerous for Benjamin
yeah that's that's true does not that
think it's a position with very little
risk yeah I agree with that statement
and that's what actually what we're
looking for from Benjamin he's kind of
the only player on our team who hasn't
favored against everybody so if he can
just kind of maybe score two points go
go for a level score will be very very
happy with that result
yeah I mean our opponents team has like
a solid all four of them are like 26
plus so mm-hmm
I feel like for Benjamin it's it's like
more of an because he is also 26 wait I
thought he was 26 50 there
but yeah he's also like right in between
the opponents yeah so I feel like for
him it's more of a battlefield than
right Benjamin box kind of playing
playing his peers here can be can be
difficult especially with being on the
slew team I guess yeah it's playing some
rivals from from Webster yes specially
because we all like qualified slew and
Webster builds qualifies for final four
right so that would be very interesting
too so he's already playing some of his
components that you might be facing and
final four yeah and this one Queen takes
d5 the black pieces are slightly loose
for kind of just a moment here I know I
wonder if there's any way to take
advantage you could always play Bishop
takes f6 but I don't think this is
really the endgame you're looking for no
this could be a little too annoying so I
feel like it would be a better idea to
just like keep the bishop rather than
get rid of it and for the endgame
yeah I like a simple move like like
Bishop c3 here actually I think bringing
your up to the center can never be wrong
so maybe we're a d1 or rook F d1 just
just try to exchange the Queen's off
first and then try to see one yeah I'm
not sure if I'm helping the nighter or
hurting the knight by bringing it to d5
but I don't think having these BB pawns
is really a weakness I know to worried
about yeah I agree with that but I I
feel like that's a rook on f1 oh we all
really have a draw well interesting so
yeah that that game that I saw between
Dominguez purlins they did agree to to a
draw which is not the most unexpected
result although it would have been nice
to see maybe a different opening choice
from from Dominguez there because he is
an incredibly strong board too and we
kind of need to score some points
against these lower boards for Webster
yeah but he also had the black pieces
and so I mean what can you really do if
after Spanish
that's right well you could answer that
play like Bobby v6 Bishop g7 and and
kind of go for for some craziness here
yeah I like this position quite a lot Oh
so what's actually going on now this is
this is a little crazy you see the the
white bishops on a1 and a2 not the most
Orthodox placement but they they do spy
some very long this goes nice on e5 on
e7 they look so nice but the Knights
cover a lot of squares you can maybe
imagine though f4 might be coming in the
future once again plays a move like king
h1 kind of prepare it a little bit then
all of a sudden that then I'm a knight
on e5 might not be so stable yeah that's
true but at the same time like something
like f4 could also create more
weaknesses because let's say okay I have
to repeat what do you want to do I can
get one sure I'll play King h1 just for
the sake of arguing oh well no I'll take
on before just for the sake break sure
but I was going to say that the knight
on e7 could be coming up to c6 right and
then that's offer to exchange Knights
could be getting interesting yes instead
we seen 8c - a lot of things that are
kind of wobbly it's kind of a really
weird placement of the pieces for white
here but they actually cover almost
every square on the Queen side yeah so
it's difficult to see how how fabi's
gonna try and I think quick okay for
might be like a dirty trick yeah sure
wicked for those bishop yeah and I'm
like you could try to do like a seven or
a piece and rook a six and then I really
wanted to try and take have enough tempo
to play 96 and then
Knight to d3 okay yeah I mean we're it'd
be eight I think seems seems totally
fine for for Fabi here yeah I mean what
black kinda has a clear plan rather than
white and we do CF for now and this
night comes into d3 like you're
mentioning pot at seven could that be
well it's been captured but I think the
problem was what if I take a one and
then yeah that's what I was thinking
not what Fabi does what that work
actually um apparently not for some
reason maybe there's Bishop b3 in the
end just defending the knight on c2 and
then the other night so it's come to c6
maybe trying to do Knight to e5 yeah and
then I think Nate
rook b1 maybe for white is somehow
trading off enough pieces but instead
rook F 8 from Fabi is the idea and it
looks like he's just gonna pick up this
f4 upon in return so I'm also going to
see a noir most likely something draw
ish it's looking pretty drawn but so
it's kind of a unique endgame where
there's more pieces on the board than
pawns but with all these nights and well
now after after Rick f3 maybe metaphor
money gift like some chances due to him
having a bishop yeah like bishops in the
endgame but probably it shouldn't be
enough I think like you yeah that's like
you kind of have to do that cuz if you
look like f7 early years rook teachers
okay 456 right I would be hanging so but
yet not Knight f4 and we we have
material equality again black has the
bishop in exchange for a night for white
this is the type of endgame it that
should always be a draw but you get the
feeling Bobby's gonna try for a while
yeah no reason not the thing is like if
the position if there were like some
cons on the Queen side
have better chances because of the
bishop right but especially because like
a game is so one-sided I mean in one
side of the board right there I think
yeah my prediction is this will end in a
draw you can imagine though some funny
business where there's some sacrifice of
one of the the Black Knight for both of
the kingside pawns and trying to make a
queen on that side of the board but
definitely a draw to be sure so let's
take a look at books game I'm a little
worried about that honestly ah they
would this go into this too they ended
up going into this endgame so we did
just see rook do ya know 94 but Benjamin
picked up this pause yes using this and
after Bishop c5 I I guess the the
placement of the white pieces are are a
little yeah that's what I was thinking
um so can we really defend all of our
stuff seems difficult I think you kind
of I feel like Bishop c5 you kind of
have to take it I might it just feels
like you have to because if you don't
then Bishop d4 is going and after 94
there could be Ruby - okay - yeah Bishop
takes c5 seems very very nice yeah
Bishop c5 most likely Knight c5 because
the Knights with attack in v3 ah so this
is an Internet so from from Benjamin
actually 91 hits the rook and forces
black to do something and after rookie -
why not King f1 that's all thank you
confused
seems like King f1 would possibly be
trappin though I'm thinking what king of
fun something like do I have two more
well I think you have to play rook d2
and then after your tasty - Knight takes
to - King you - Knight e4 and all of the
black pieces are somehow being held
together
huh guess so
looks just barely actually somehow this
this ended up being dangerous for Ray
but that looks like a very forcing line
and then I think we should have no
thinking if this should be played like I
don't think there should be any other
move to spend time on because yeah I
mean you could still just kind of play
Bishop takes e5 c5 and you move like b4
and the knight d3 is defending all of
White's weaknesses but um I I think I do
like this King f1 line instead because
it gets the King closer to the center it
gets you closer to just a straight minor
piece endgame where your king is gonna
be a lot more active thanks to use extra
extra time yeah so the two series well
kind of its don't think you want us to
take take in King iguana we just saw the
Benjamin chose take after about two
minutes in half I guess something like
that yeah so Bishop takes d c5 is his
choice maybe in that line that I was
saying black could take on d4 rather
than move the knight again but
regardless we do have this endgame now
and it looks like b4 it would be the
most natural move to my eyes it gives
you time to play Knight d3 and make sure
all your all your weaknesses are covered
for the moment so Benjamin looking like
he's going to be up a pawn in this
endgame but not a very very useful yeah
because like if you play before now
Knight a four let's just say for the
sake of the argument okay nine a four
maybe then I can play b3 that's c3 yeah
okay and I guess I can play York c1 but
then you have some some some some
forking tricks yeah I feel like this
nights gonna keep jumping around yeah
this I can can get annoying as
but also if you don't really play b4
then I mean that's your only chance to
keep the pawn or you can give it up
so just King f1 from Benjamin allowing
Europe takes b2 but then I suppose maybe
he's he's planning just to play like a
knight d3 move and trade off these
Knights and go straight for a draw yeah
I guess I mean that's that's a very
reasonable approach to this game
honestly you wouldn't be able to do so
many I mean anything with your palms
anyways right yeah this one
this one I think is as the deadest draw
of of the bunch here this wreck endgame
shouldn't be anything for anybody yeah
Oh actually he offered Benjamin offer to
drop raise is still thinking yeah we'll
see what ray decides to do about it I
mean well I do want to check back in
with Wesley so it seems like his game is
the most interesting game left and it
looks like material is equal for the
moment but the black King might be
running into some danger but also the
white King might be running into some
danger danger everywhere yeah I think
though the white king does does seem to
be a bit safer here there's no real way
for blacks to maneuver this Knight to a
square like f1 which would which would
kind of be the move needed to to get at
this white came here meanwhile green f8
is preparing to move like rook d8 maybe
and Queen takes f7 as well also
obviously a threat I think ilya has some
problems in this position yeah I mean
how would you even try to get out of it
quick
well I move like Queen c7 I guess is
defending the f7 pawn for the moment and
if you play rook d8 I don't think there
is an immediate threat of checkmate so I
do have some time to try and play some
some more moves to either defend my king
or get
your king instead we see Queen g5 and I
don't know what the plan is after after
Queen f7 95 is a fork but there's maybe
a queen a - but then Queens c1 I don't
it's too too complicated
these look like a blunder we just see
rook d8 instead now o we also have a
result on Fabiano's game draw so Fabi
also not managing to get a full point
but he does get to a draw yeah listen I
want to keep focus on this game because
I think this is the this would be the
decisive game of this round yeah I agree
I think Benjamin Bach is definitely
going to end up with a draw in his game
and so it's really just down to two
Wesley so here and and what he can make
happen in this very interesting position
where both Kings coming under a little
bit of fire yeah
so this 95 move actually comes with a
pretty serious threat of Knight g4 check
yes if white were to capture that in
Queen h4 is is a checkmate so but to my
eyes I'm wondering what's wrong with
Queen g8 check King g6 and d6 yeah I
guess so you have to play simply f6 yeah
worst you have the Queen e8 check but
then the king can come back to to h7 and
it's a little unclear how you actually
break through
was there any thing after Queen g5 was
there anything else that they could have
done um instead of rook d8 maybe there
was according to the engine Knight f5
was the only move to really win the game
cuz like that makes a lot of sense it
just prepares rook g3 and then the game
is kind of over but it was actually a
missed opportunity for less it's just
biggest like it just I don't know it
feels like there should be something
here because I feel like it's more like
a fights between the Knights whose lines
would be more active at the end yeah I
like here in this specific situation
ideally you would want to play Knight at
five but you can't because of Knight f4
f3 so I feel like that's the problem
when the knight was on c4 Knight f5
probably was you know well the knight
was on c4 and also the rook was on d3
yeah you can respond to any Queen at
four check with rook g3 which would have
really only served to help your attack
but now with the rook on d6 and the
knight on e5 everything is a lot more
more active back in another endgame yeah
this is not truly going the way I wanted
to go yeah I mean that being said it
could have gone a lot worse
Wesley committed or anything but now in
this end game I don't expect Wesley to
be able to do much here although the
knight is attacked after Knight of seven
rook d7 there's some pressure along just
seven I mean you can just try and give
some checks yeah
ninety-seven my g6 check check check and
we might actually just see a draw here
by by repetition overall it was pretty
hard game to try and manage for both
sides and I think the night Queen g5
night f5 I mean if it was a classic game
as they would have found it
yeah no questions there but you know in
rabbit they would take yeah
I mean I'm not complaining well goodness
so Wesley decides to play on place and
yeah the game continues I guess playing
on this time pressure but I mean Wesley
does have to be a little bit careful
here those those Queen side pawns for
black could could get rolling oh okay g3
the Knights attacked you have to do
something yeah probably
uh there's a check up on g3 news
Wesley's choice and now we have this
exchange up endgame very interesting
decision by Ilya to go for this I guess
he's confident in his ability to to hold
this position I mean but you don't think
he's the one playing for a win anymore
that's true that's what it is exactly
that being said this looks actually to
be a very simple fortress yeah I mean
she's gonna y-you can't actually Oh Shh
that's that's a tough one
that's a tough one to see Wesley so
blunders this Fork and loses the game
actually Wow okay not what I expected to
see from the end of that game and oh my
god Benjamin Bach
looks to be in a little bit of trouble
as well wait what happened I don't know
how this the second game got to this
point this should not be losing but it's
it's not the easiest thing I've ever
seen
like it shouldn't be losing though in
fact maybe I can can start picking up
some of these pawns if like isn't
careful
okay while we're f4 so don't capture
that rook alright I'm on board
it is some pretty serious time pressure
here
I know King g2 is a good move keep the
King off the back rank
okay another ruck comes behind something
to give some annoying checks from the
8th ring but
and yeah now King age - okay you can
yeah you can just take this do you ever
see three if you need it oh but now
f4 is a very very nice smooth and is
this is this simply a draw I mean the f4
pawn according to my theory should be
but this is a I I don't I don't know my
Rekha and games well enough to tell you
ideally it would be okay in this
specific situation I feel like it is a
draw because the King on the short side
means that the one thing that I do know
is for the pawn on G the king could be
passively in like g1 for white and
there's real quick passively just be
hanging on f1 and stuff but for the pawn
if the White House to actually play
active I mean maybe not that active
because the clingen g4 is a little
worrying me it's over so Benjamin Bach
does manage to hold this in game which
is important news for us because Leslie
so hanging that unfortunate fork really
not what we hope to see in that game so
that brings the the total score to not
one to two but I think one-and-a-half to
two this that's true uh could have been
one two three could have been one two
three very very easily
should have been tuna too though yeah
yeah because Leslie did have the upper
hand in his game pretty much all game
except when he entered the endgame it
was a little rough for him - yeah but
find the exact he declined the
repetition he wanted to play on then he
was up the exchange and it was just a
clear fortress I feel like he pushed too
hard sometimes that happens when you're
like pushing away through hard times it
pays off and sometimes I mean there were
no chances for the opponent to actually
like
yeah even if you play g5h g5f that's
it's still like there's still like well
maybe there but not very very important
for Wesley but okay we have some very
very strong players on our team I don't
think we're we're too deep in the hole
here this is I think the first time the
Archbishop's have been behind in a match
though I don't think that has ever
happened yet historically so breaking
new ground here in Chicago wins now this
is the team that mike comer said we
would have to be on the lookout for this
I agree that's me said this is actually
this this um this thing is I feel like I
think this and the canadaboys yeah the
Canada chess bras yeah I feel like these
two teams are the teams to win if we are
going for the first which we still are
but I feel like yeah these two teams are
the teams that we would have to cross
because these two are I mean yeah
they're objectively the roughest yeah
these are the toughest teams I think in
the division and here we see the results
Bobby of course only managing a draw
against quesada Perez who's on Batista
drew Lenny and Dominguez as well in a
very very quick game and wisely so goes
down to Ilya nice neck in this end game
where he unfortunately blundered a night
fork Benjamin bak does hold the draw
against Ray Robson on our board for and
this is a kind of an unusual score for
round one in the protest lake usually
round one is the the biggest niche
mismatch yeah players they usually get
you know two wins on boards one and two
and two losses on boards three and four
but in this case a lot of draws these
players maybe more evenly matched than
we think
yeah I mean just looking at their
ratings there's not much difference
between their first word and last boards
right there's so difference yeah but
strength wise I feel like through
pretty much saying yes that's what that
ends that in mind these are the pairings
for round two but like you were saying a
lot of these players close to the same
level so these ones are all gonna be
pretty similar actually in terms of of
the scores so we have Ray Robson against
Wesley so on board one for Chicago board
three for us actually
Ilya nish Nick against Benjamin Bach
that's their board two against our board
for Fabiana Cara wanna against bruising
Batista and finally Lenny a Dominguez
against yes circus out of Perez on our
board too and their board for I think
mixed up yeah it gets a little bit weird
and rounds two and three whether they're
kind of transitioning through up to the
the one-to-one match ups but this is
what we have to look forward to in round
two now I think we're just waiting for
the games to yeah okay so who do you
think will be the first sort team to win
Bobby yes
and then Wesley and then Dominguez and
then Ben Benjamin honestly I'm looking
for solid yeah I think that's definitely
the strategy he should be going for is
it's just scoring some solid points
getting his drawers and while he can
because that's what we really need from
board for we don't need board for to be
scoring three four points two and a half
we just need a couple points the kid we
were playing last time oh yeah mark
Marcus Harvey with a near 2800 level
performance in the process League yeah
so it's just one who's talking like
board for ideally keeping it strong it
just he just popped up in my brain and I
was like wow yeah that guy I managed to
keep it's really we don't need we don't
need that much from Benjamin Bach we
just need need a couple points to make
sure that we we walk away with a win in
this match and I think now we're just
waiting for the chess calm people to get
this next year and started as they are
on a little bit of a break I think so
before this round started I had a little
quick look at the the standings it looks
like we are actually a point and a half
behind going into today the Canada chess
for us so I think then the chess prowess
and us are actually the only two teams
to win in the first two weeks I think
the other teams all went one and one or
oh and two for a couple teams but so
it's just down to us and them who are
still undefeated and they did I think
win today against the Brazil capybaras
and kind of another blowout so they are
still solidly in the lead so if we want
to catch up to them
we got a yeah but I feel like this this
is this specific match for us it's more
about like we didn't get solid and
keeping it's definitely one of the ones
where we just we want to walk away with
eight and a half yes yes so I feel like
as long as we crossed the Webster boys
yes yeah and then like I feel like after
that actually whoever playing next time
next week I am not sure who we have but
I know that in week five that is when we
have our chance against the Canada chest
for us so that'll definitely be one to
watch yes
looks like next week we have the
California unicorns Oh
be on the lookout for them I don't know
too much about that team but I do know
that week five is us against the king of
the chess brothers well I was trying to
deter them like evaluates our chances
when is the time that you're actually
gonna have team that I can actually go
for 14 to 16 we can actually do what
score like 14 points 16 points yeah well
it looks like the next round is underway
so let's go ahead and take a look at
these games so we have Bobby against but
Bautista Bautista I'm bad the
pronunciation sorry yeah uh-oh it's add
another Lopez
another open as long as it's not Berlin
I'd love to watch it okay so I don't
actually know much of the theory um but
I prepared this a lot with white at some
point in my life there are like some
crazy stuff I
it looks pretty natural for white here
he's just developing all those pieces
black does get an early defy but maybe
this pun is gonna end up being a little
bit weak to my eyes yeah I feel like the
next I mean right now it looks more like
a somewhat normal Lopez because this
night we'll try to come to the b1 nights
with ideally try to come and jump around
a little right but because this nights
here there's a chance that it'll just
get traded off so that's something
that's it depends if black would
continue with something like night c5 or
not so I'm kind of expecting actually
move like Bishop c5 and maybe black
tries to play this move d4 although
actually looking at it it seems
difficult to achieve
I mean yeah just from what I remember
from a while ago preparing this there is
a line with Bishop c5 but I feel like
instead of push up East 7 you should
have played like a earlier Bishop c5 and
then yeah there are the ideas with d4
and stuff but I'm just remembering a
really really crazy game I think for me
to say those rapid and blitzes where it
looks somewhat like this and black
pushes this pawn like all the way to d3
and then it just stays there for the
whole game I do remember preparing
something like that yeah I don't think
it was quite the same as this one though
we do see a knight B to d2 and maybe
black will be trading this off you have
to make some decision with this efore
Knight because it's currently under
threat
so either a knight takes d2 or 95 I
think is what is my c5 it would be the
more feisty way to go yeah but maybe
Bishop c2 is something White's happy to
do anyways nothing about to be hopeful
for your opponent do you want some
advice be sure I think this should see
to yes the most sense and then there's
some c4 stuff coming up move like b4
forces this night away and then some
things like 23 do become possible and
the thing it was like there's always
this if you do get to play before and in
long a lot of long run you could
consider something like a 4 because if
there's takes an a6 pawn is really weak
and it's no not taking and b5 phone is
under attack with Queen I definitely
agree yeah we do see Bishop g4 from
black not a move I was really expecting
but I guess he's just trying to loosen
White's control over this e5 pawn a
little bit we'd see 93 from Fabi
so he's responding to this threat to his
knight on f3 by going after the pawn on
d5 it looks like so if Bishop takes f3
here I imagine we'll just see Queen f3
and then if Knight takes e5 Queen takes
d5 as possible and it's just a simple
trade of pawns and white will have the
bishop pair with an open Center yeah
I mean I transpose openings but I feel
like for me if I didn't know the opening
90 p3 wouldn't be one of the moves that
I was I would be considering yeah it's
not the most natural yeah because you
tend to want to recapture an f3 with the
night instead of the Queen or obviously
the pawn which I guess is an option here
but 93 is a very active try I think to
get rid of this night on the c5 bring
this bishop back to b3 and go after this
week deep on that being said there are
three other games oh yeah I sometimes
when you start to focus games and just
stay there yes yeah it is difficult to
it so look away sometimes yeah which
one's the openings are just like who one
of your openings and you're just like
wow yes sir I don't remember my own face
yeah
so this is Linear's game it was a nice
efore a5 going
starting in okay of course it's yeah
it's a Liam a4 and the nice eat seven
okay at least I'm glad I played the
right openings with my okay so if Bishop
b3 Bishop these settings and this is our
current position I'm actually not really
familiar with this Bishop d7 idea yeah
me as well I I don't have too much
knowledge in this deep deep theoretical
apes' but I always thought like your
ideas try and push for d5 was black so
you would want to play something like
Bishop e6 well yeah I mean it looks like
like is is still kind of obeying this
this rule but instead of e-cigs he put
this fish upon to c6 where it does put
some more pressure on on white Center in
the king
like you can imagine after move like d5
so I think a very similar idea to Bishop
e6 just picking a different square for
this Bishop of course d5 looks natural
for white trying to attack this this
Bishop but you don't want to open up
that diagonal as well as close off your
own yes also the other thing is as soon
as you close off the center then you're
gonna get bombarded so it sounds like
night at four exact nights the other
night Mills and some crazy F fives will
jump in the game it's I wouldn't I mean
I would like that as black all right
yeah
d5 usually usually not a good move here
this much I unless you see like a clear
clear advantage that like you do you
have everything ready you play d5 and
then you're rushing in with likes you
can immediately do something like c5
right yeah I think that's would be
something to keep in mind let's take a
look at Bach books okay well so a
Benjamin Bach
ants alienation egg and here it looks
like I'm just gonna do a really quick
what has that so okay normal song
Catalan an open Catalina one thing that
I was told not to do and cattle - Black
was to not be greedy about the pawns
I only greedy yeah that's something that
I was told not to do but again I didn't
have the best of coaches up or also the
best I've talked about this yeah yeah it
looks like things that have kind of
worked out for Benjamin here though this
position seems perfectly reasonable okay
it scares me but yeah yeah yeah nice
he's getting a little little attacked on
the Kings side just a little this e4
pawn definitely is is worthwhile it's
worth keeping around I think I feel like
if that fish of instead of Eason wasn't
g7 it would make me feel so much safer I
think he's on his way
g5 and if
like queen g4 I think we can expect
Bishop h6 and then this Bishop will be
will be landing on the g7 square or
maybe just staying on h6 even keeping a
tabs on the bishop on c1 you can expect
this knight to come to d5 maybe adding
more pressure to e3 and then I guess
blacks kind of just gonna be trying to
hold down the fort here on the Kings
side
well while White's trying to break it
open
oh yeah I think what you said is pretty
accurate description of ideally what was
happen but let's focus on that so yeah
what do you think White's ideas are
though i was waiking at shrines and get
at the king here there's always a first
like sacrifices to consider on g6 and
maybe that's why Benjamin cheese is
queen d8 to prevent this claim from
looking at the g6 pawn I feel like if
you if as black you are fast enough to
bring in your knight and like bring your
knife back to for less a d5 right um you
could theoretically still be in time but
so what if what if Bishop g6 question I
guess or something like rook f2 right
now the idea is to take on g6 and then
take on easy
I think if you give me a tenth off I'm
gonna play King g7 and then with my Jeep
on a little bit more defendant and Queen
takes a so she's not coming with check I
think it's a lot safer
yeah and that fisherman c1 looks like a
tall pond so yeah yeah yeah I take that
no no no no no 50
I don't know player kits to anymore um
[Music]
yeah I actually I think it like
Benjamin's position here unless white
proves something pretty quickly
he's just gonna have a much more
favorable position on the Queen side
where things like B 4 and C 3 are in
fact gonna come
with some pretty strong effects this
night might also end up on the d3 square
as well as d5 so that's me to look out
for and yeah I think Ilya really needs
to come up with a concrete idea right
now or else or else Benjamin's gonna
gonna kind of start running away with
this one I like the sound of that I mean
I don't really know what white
how would white want to try and improve
I accept like some crazy sacrifices but
I don't think they work actually because
even if bishop g 6f g6 bishop what do
you want to do oh wow so we see King G
teams from white to bring the record the
H file so I guess just King g7 as black
should be good enough makes sense to me
and if King g7 what kind of life do
something like for kids wanna baby
uh yeah Berk h1 is always going to be
met with with your okay Jade of course
and then I'm really not sure how you
continue with with Wyatt and this is the
problem I think with Ilyas position
whereas with black you know King g7 is
very natural 95 is very natural yeah and
then once I'm I'm confident and my
King's safety I can play things like B
for things like c3 and make some some
concrete threats on that side of the
board yeah I was just thinking if you
guys whites could use like could you
like move the e4 Bishop and then try and
push efore it weakens d4 and also where
do you where you actually put this
bishop from a forest there's another
tough question I think maybe for white
you might try to activate this Bishop
via the d2 square but then I'm not sure
where you really go after that so but
let's say King g7 and white plays Bishop
d2 I guess that's as asking for 95 and
then I'm not I'm not sure what the next
move is for ilya really
so I think I'm saying this one I like
for Benjamin okay yeah I agree with that
let's take a look at who today we look
at we have not seen dominguez's game I
believe yeah so he is up against
Quesada Perez here and we have another
it is really scary honestly yeah Lenny a
does does this where he gets into some
pretty serious time pressure but this
this guy has nerves of steel I don't if
I want my players to have at least half
the time remaining out of the game
yeah it is it is difficult so we do see
II takes d5 though and it doesn't make
this decision it's like a quick look at
so we saw up until some somewhere around
here right he's NME talking about
sometimes I said before oh wow
Oh closing up so notably though he
closes it up after he he takes off this
light solution that's actually pretty
smart and now you you're going for this
square while you still have your dark
colored bishop to keep your squares safe
oh yeah so that's why we see black play
so actively though trading off in the
center immediately before white has time
to bring these Knights into the game and
now we have this position where White
has this extra C pawn in exchange for
blacks EEP on I guess it's gonna be a
question of how useful blacks a pawn is
is going to be it really supports this F
Foursquare for the Black Knights but
maybe it can also be a little bit of a
weakness with the knight on f3 and the
rook on he won both aimed at this pawn
so as why I guess he's deciding whether
or not he wants to take off these these
Queens and he decides yes okay yes I
think we can just was a pretty smart and
decisive idea because if you wouldn't
have done the Queen exchange then you
would you wouldn't really know how to
improve like where would why are you
trying to place your Knights as white
yeah
no it's it's not so difficult I want to
play maybe night ff12 d2 and then I can
kind of take my pick of of c4 or Eve or
depending on what the situation calls
for I want for c4 yeah I like c4 as well
you just have to be careful that some
that Pawnee four isn't ever gonna be
strong I think well so we've seen I have
three go okay and I guess this is
partially looking to step out of the
move e5 to e4 which would have hit the
night yeah
in the previous length plus I think if
you then look at the best Liso scheme oh
that's forgetting about I'm not really
forgetting but yes yeah this position
doesn't look that looks to be a no no
nice it's a little harder to hang a rook
to a rook for although he maybe he'll
get skewered I don't want to say say
anything no no this is this would be an
easy draw right yeah absolutely in fact
Wesley goes to pick up this epon no yeah
and then probably you're something I
mean depends on what what white once but
if white doesn't want to fight anymore
rupees six would be a good way to call
it cause a day you could tell me twice
but also try to play something like b5
now take and then take back or place
like a six some some ideas there but I
think I'd be at the end of the day with
and absolutely no danger here in fact if
anything I think he might be winning up
oh my god glasses is that 10 seconds
eyes he sees down to ten seconds b5 was
this choice now I think rookie 2 is the
correct way to yeah rook takes b5 maybe
and after okay six I think this is the
end game that Ray Robson is going to
hope straw but but this one it's a draw
yeah with two seconds on the clock and
you know anything can can really happen
yeah and it's not the classic four
versus three where all of whites pawns
are connected yeah it's a four verse
verse 3 where this e pawn it's a little
bit lonely on the e4 square but I still
okay this is still a draw I mean it
would take a miracle ona cards yeah I
think that that'd be fair to say but you
know you never know Wesley so he's a
tricky guy he got tricky last game but
we'll see what he can he can do in this
round but ok objectively how would he
try to push would you try to do so maybe
something like yeah that's like age 4
and now oh you're thinking g5 I was
thinking maybe g6 and f5 and and we can
try and play like this for the past a
pawn are you god he's got to go
somewhere right down to his final final
seconds here this is very dangerous I
love it
homies opportunities for our team yeah I
mean what do I mean maybe
where you going my man who keeps recheck
ah I think some crazy things are
happening in Fabiano Carolina's game so
maybe we should take a look at this one
I can't wear yeah I mean this you can
game with right down to two seconds is
something but Bobby's position here is
is off the Y I just saw that thick boats
have enough time I was like eh we'll
come back to that later
yeah I just what's going on here though
well for and is there a night takes more
but the night takes g6 with in 1906 back
in the nookie 7 and the night 8 9
how many rooks does black have I'll hold
on a second what's going on here
what is how are you are you referring to
good friends
well it's it's chess as a draw of course
it was never in doubt but but what is
going on here
King g7 not the move I would have seen
coming from black but it makes sense
yeah you stepping on a night
exactly but all kind of gnarly night of
sevens to follow and all the pins of g6
pawn yeah that was actually pretty smart
though right I am all for King g7 but
where where it is white what is White's
next move even it how do you take
advantage of this you can just move this
night maybe back to f3 and then you have
rookie 6 pin ideas things like this
should be 3 things like Knight g5 might
all be strong singing sounds like Knight
g4 and then you watch you for like three
minutes six just to I was pushing it
back again I think maybe Knight g4 I I
do have time to play rook f5 and then
there's things like rook h5 to worry
about if you want to go in fear for
Queen she's Queen h6 rather
I don't know a very complicated position
here well we'll see what Fabi comes up
with but this is this is a crazy one to
be sure and simply g3 is as fabi's
choice defending his F pawn what what a
way to play chess so now I guess things
like Nigeria a little bit more of a
serious threat since f4 is defended so
things like Rica for wouldn't wouldn't
be a possibility
Oh as a result yeah
Wesley wins this endgame time
not even on time on resignation like we
said this the second game was a little
bit more tricky than maybe we were
giving it credit for
black did go for g5 and then actually
managed to pick up all of the kingside
pawns and and that's all it takes to go
away so let's see lozenger pretty last
question of minutes Rana this game
should have also been the draw so yeah
over this one I mean this this one was
not easy for for Raven the last one was
just it was a bit silly but Wesley so
definitely going for some Redemption
here gets the full point against Trey
Robson board one for the Chicago wind
let's take a look at the Benjamins King
because it's been a while since we took
a look at it and that bitch's game
progress has been made for both sides
here blacks no longer getting checkmated
which is good but white has solved most
of his problems I think his structural
problems as well as this the C pawn is
notably missing now
[Music]
but I'm still kind of shocked of how
like you should do to then Bishop c3 and
then what happened to d4 pawn yes it was
a pawn on d4 I don't know
oh we have another ah
Dominguez actually lost this game Wow
because it felt like I mean the last
time I looked at it it was somewhere
around the Queen's were out off the
boards
and she was we just saw 92 and then
Knight c4 maybe that was a little slow
yeah it looks like black got to push
this this F pawn and the rooks invaded
along this F file and became very very
annoying and then Wow
too many guys just hung a piece just
just sung his knight on e4 it looks like
at the end of the game
we're what yeah just work T to hang
hangs hangs a night some unfortunate
blunders from from her team here today
but we're definitely not out of it why
don't we check back in on Bobby's game
as they are down to their at their final
final seconds looks like Bobby has won
material back he was down the exchange
now it looks like he won a full piece
back in return
oh wait what oh and Benjamin bark has
fallen to Ilya nish Nick as well okay
we'll take a look at that though let's
let's stick with Bobby because this game
I think is nearing its this is the last
game of the round actually and Queenie
five looks like checkmate
looks like check everybody agrees yeah
every everybody Wow so that was kind of
a wild finish to that one but at the end
of the day - - - in around - yeah we're
still one one down dome yeah that that's
a fair point we are I mean the wins but
yeah yeah this was a crazy round so
Wesley so beats ray in a rock n game we
should be a draw
Bobby beats Batista in this crazy crazy
like wild game where it looks like he
was there and he sacrificed an exchange
at some point but just look at this
attack
Dominguez just hangs a night against
quesada Perez and then Ilene is Nick
defeats Benjamin Bach somehow we were
unsure this is I mean we we were looking
at its when the bishop wasn't still here
yeah it looks like ah gave those really
nice early just snag this this this deep
on of nowhere and that was
and maybe some of nights going to d3 in
this revision I should've went to d5
but then this year 585 may be simply six
maybe that's what's he was worried about
well maybe you can still play Queen
takes d5 and I guess the tactics don't
don't quite work know there's the
probably four would be enough to yeah he
four attacks the wishbones you find that
twice which is the problem so clean the
eight isn't enough to defend so 93 and
then yeah we see the c4 Khan fall off
actually the Queen he just pretty smart
because you're trying what why can't you
try and yeah
what's idea about queenie 8 that's what
I'm trying to figure out cuz oh well
it's not like you can white can only
play d5 because II for Bishop d2 right
rook f3 I'm sure there's some crazy
location to somewhere yeah I'm not sure
maybe maybe he was trying to force d5 to
try and get this pawn back but only kind
of like opens that up yeah I think he
just underestimated a White's activity
in the Sun yeah d4 is really strong and
the bishop blacks call it bishop but you
can't really do anything anymore it's
kind of locked out of the game you know
usually you want to have the bishop on
on the other color to your to your home
funds but here the white bishop was
really holding together all of whites
weaknesses and so we added or Bock
rather had to trade off this bishop to
even attack any of these pawns and now
this is the second game I think it's
just hopeless yeah the the pawns are way
too advanced yeah this is not the way I
was kind of hoping it's to go um yeah so
that's that's round 2 and even though
it's not going quite quite the way we
had hoped to to to and round 2 it is not
an awful score we are just one point
behind after that second round Wesley so
of course defeating Ray Robson Benjamin
doc falling to iliyan is Nick Bobby
defeating razón Batista and Lenny a
Dominguez actually falling to yeah
circus nada Perez after he he blundered
blunder tonight so that's that's blunder
that's the second blunder in two rounds
for our team people keep your pieces
pieces over here get sad when you lose
your pieces alright so with that in mind
it is four and a half to three and a
half and maybe we'll take just a quick
break while we wait for round 3 to get
started here yeah
yeah yeah I think that's that's a good
idea there half a there all right
so join us in just a few minutes for
round three yep when you visit st. Louis
you'll probably want to watch the
Cardinals for the Blues what about after
the game heading back to the hotel would
be a major error instead boogie through
the city and discover the music that
gave the Blues their name at the
National Blues Museum Broadway Oyster
Bar or even the legendary Blueberry Hill
so whether you love the Cardinals the
Blues or the Blues come play with us and
you guys know I can't play this right
st. Lou is always exploring be surprised
be intrigued be delighted the world
chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
we get your autograph yeah of course I
think it's pretty cool that you love
chess so much we love chess ooh enjoy
school chess program and gotta meet a
real-life Grandmaster I got you this big
one time I put please captain after
school and check wait a min 27 moves wow
I should be asking for your autographs
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis Chess Club org
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of fame cutting-edge exhibitions feature
rare historic chess artifacts paired
with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
you may have heard about st. Louis's
world-class museums art history science
even magic
[Music]
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by you
[Music]
whose kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
no matter your age or skill level chess
is a great game to learn and play the
same lose chess club offers affordable
memberships for families students and
individuals there's so much going on at
the club with lectures classes ladies
nights and tournaments in addition
there's always a Grand Master in
residence to help teach learn and play
come join us at the st. Louis chess club
and see what chess has to offer
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error you through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill
so whether you love the Cardinals the
Blues or the Blues come play with us you
guys know I can't play this right st.
Lou is always exploring hello and
welcome back to round three of the
protest league of course my name is
Caleb nd I'm joined by the wonderful
International Master Dorsett Eric Schadt
thank you you're welcome
yeah going so yeah we have the game it's
been Ilya and Bobby going on and even
though it's barely I mean almost they're
on the move 21 um they have already
entered uh yeah I guess you could call
this a nun game there's still a couple
pieces on the board as well as both
trucks from both sides it looks like
there's some pressure along this F file
yeah Bobby's gonna have to deal with
um but for the moment he he is actually
up upon wishes yeah I wanted to take a
quick look at the opening okay so some
sort of an English opening well curious
how did you win the palm like just just
kind of launched this pawn forward to fi
yeah f5 probably was not the smartest
move
because now you get this 95 and you do
this manure and the f5 pond is really
weak uh yeah it looks like it's it's a
little awkward for white to try to
defend it but yeah so white played this
move Knight e4 actually looking just to
trend offers some activity here so after
94 black does capture the pawn but then
white gets this move 96 and Bishop takes
f5 yes exactly we got to where we are
right now actually played five more
[Music]
Wow this so it looks like Bobby is
maintaining the extra pawn for just a
moment here but I mean after rook f8 you
have to imagine where d8 is Bobby's
response and then after rook f7
you would think d7 and this might just
be a repetition
I mean well let's keep in mind that's
puppey is black and the win I mean with
black it's really hard to fight when
white is like um happy with the draw
yeah I definitely agree but we do need
to start scoring some points here
keeping in mind that we are down down a
point after after those first two rounds
score of course three and a half to four
and half so we need to catch up in the
near future
um I agree I let's get this game a
little bit of time and see if they come
up with something else who else can't
even see we can check out Wesley sosman
yeah he has why it's against I can't say
uni s key case out of Perez and looks
like he has a little bit of a spatial
advantage in the center with these I I'm
I like White's position that's my
position I stand with it
there's something wrong yeah I don't
really disagree one thing to keep in
mind though is that black does have this
d5 square so if Black gets its a couple
spare moments to play maybe this night
now back to e7 and into d5 yes things
might start looking up but the question
is does he have time to really do
something I'm thinking maybe whites
could start pushing crazy right now
maybe something like if it works maybe
Queen e4 and oh yeah so instead this 92
moved like you said is aiming for the d6
square so you can see something like
Knight c4 or 94 both aim to put this
knife into d6 where it will wreak some
havoc in the black camp so Queen d5 for
the moment stops both 94 and 94 I feel
like what that's why she could think
about the Queen for more seriously now
yeah quit it for pinning pending the
night yeah and then you have the ideas
with rook c1 or 94 and I feel like those
would be valid concerns for black or
simply rook c1 and in 94 is still coming
you have to wonder though how safe the
black king is going to be if it simply
just cast his Kings side I think this
might be what what Perez is planning
here
well if simple castle can't you just
play something like f4 is why it's
immediately oh yeah f4 I guess looks
like an interesting idea too to open
things up at some point though you might
have to like address if if Knight takes
d4 is a very real threat I'm not sure if
it is in that position but it might be
in fact I'm not sure what happens after
Knight takes d4 in this current position
here I'll probably coin a four check
yeah something like ninety five students
really work at that position but what
I'm singing is if if something I'm sure
it's castle maybe even queen g4 first to
defend it to supposedly different d4 and
keep the ideas with f4 and like that
should be even stronger if something
like when G for f5 works yeah I think I
like this Queen G for a movie I wouldn't
be convinced about f5 for black and so I
guess f4 is is really just gonna you're
gonna be a permanent problem for if
you'd like to deal with maybe also
there's a night C for for for white here
keeping with the original plan I'm just
bringing this night into d6 and and then
maybe we can follow this one up with
with f4 as well uh yeah but I'm a little
worried this black could actually go
crazy and play Thank You queen g4 okay
so queen g4 is played and now what can
black do maybe this f5 move is is worth
I feel like if I was the only move that
you would actually start beat you would
actually have to have a good response to
as wyeth otherwise you're just gonna do
something like ninety four all right
so very natural is just to take on
passant with with a takes FCS and then I
guess I'm not sure how exactly black
wants to recapture but I guess we'll
never know because we see Knight East
seven instead but you know I agree with
you I think eighty four looks like a
powerful idea alright yeah f4
immediately there might be a knight f5
and then I'm not totally sure what's
happening after Bishop f2 but yeah so
you see ninety four out of five events
it might even be time for for some
sacrifices who's to say for certain do
you want to take on g5 I really kind of
do want to say this
I think with the Knights my the Knights
I meant the bishop I think I wants to
take with the bishop by the bishop I
meant I want to do with what do you want
to keep on the board well they're all
dying is the problem though what I do if
I take with the night
there's night takes III I think and so
I've take c3 and then I'll lose my my
night on g5 as well that's like Bishop
takes g5 maybe I get to keep the knight
on the board but it seems a little bit
too slow it's like Queen takes d4 in the
ends I don't think I have time really to
follow through on my threats so maybe I
just can't take this g5 pawn with that
of Mines
there's moves like c7 to consider
there's see 3 yeah Brooke c3 as well
aiming to swing over to the Kings side
ah 93 is Wesley's choice trying to kick
this night out of it's f5 home and yeah
I would think he's looking to follow
this one up with with f4 and as well so
if my g3 like Queen g3 and then up or
something like that
yeah I think so I don't think you really
want to play F takes G 3 it opens up the
F file but I don't think it's really
really worth doing here yeah I mean if
the knight was still on e4 and then you
could have the file open yeah probably I
thought yeah the knight will be gone so
sad well maybe we can sit on this game
for a little bit and check out what's
going on and some of the other ones here
yeah so what do you think of this game
between Dominguez and Dre Robson where
are my rooks where there's another
another Berlin Berlin of course it's a
Berlin
yeah so no problems for black really in
this line this one looking to be a draw
in much the same way Dominguez is round
one was a drunk so these players really
not looking to challenge Dominguez with
the white pieces but it is just because
he's Latino they have this huge that was
maybe not the best but I don't know I
think maybe he's just like one of the
best chess players in the world and do
they understand that
so with Fabien Nestle they go for the
blood yes I don't know it's very very
strange yeah well I think Fabien Wesley
both weren't playing either Berlin with
black maybe if given the opportunity
these players would be happy happy to
draw simply but Fabien Wesley just kind
of art letting them but we do see a fish
52 and I don't think we need to look at
this game ever again I just want to
point out that um one of the new emojis
that came out okay Apple was the the
owning one I thought that was pretty
interesting yeah it's a useful one to be
sure whenever I say Berlin that just
pops off in my head that's okay there's
the thing no more moves there we haven't
seen that's Benjamin doc doing here he's
doing well I think this is not not a bad
position at all for for Ben looks a
little
a little why I was going I wanted to say
something like not very straightforward
but I changed it I just want to say that
looks like it's very time consuming time
okay
I think though the position on the chess
board really does favor him though
there's this week pawn on d6
I feel like the problem is that the
bishop on d2 you don't really know what
you're doing with it and it's kind of
blocking the deal on Doc like if that's
rook from d1 was on I can see - you
would have a more much more clear idea
what you're doing
I think this Bishop on g2 is actually
pressuring before though pretty
effectively and in fact it can can might
just take this this pawn immediately I
wonder just it takes before free upon
free pawn I like those everybody wants
the free pawn I want the free pawn I'll
take the free pawn you take out free fun
everybody agrees I'm thinking is there
like in 96 95 94 any of the Knights
doing anything useful uh yeah so maybe
they're just like work be it I guess
I'll have to play Queen c3 and then
maybe for their is attacking some stuff
but it looks totally fine for for white
I think no real problems to solve and in
an extra beat pawn to boot
yes
I want to say too good to be true yes we
see Knight f5 yeah I expected 94 in the
last move honestly it's making me wonder
if I can play move like f3 here
Dawn's weak and some dark squares but I
still have this dark squared Bishop and
and black is missing it notably and it
does control the e4 square pretty well
and that being said though Benjamin Bach
doesn't need to start moving a little
bit faster he's getting getting down on
the clock here and that's not something
that he really wants I know there are
some decisions to be made though for
sure so make sense why spending the time
here but start protecting the be prom
queen d3 is this choice so this is also
aimed at stepping out of 94 but it
doesn't really commit to the move of f3
quick black still play 94 94 I think
simply a Bishop II one might might be
Benjamin here and then f3 kind of come
with tempo especially can come to f2 if
ever need be and I would like that one
that one quite a bit for white I think
simply rook a to instead iliyan is Nick
and fabi's game does end in a draw not
quite in the exact manner we were
predicting but Nina the disposition was
always just pretty equal I think I well
I do want to think another look at yeah
of course this was the Berlin between
Ray Robson and lineage Dominguez and
this one looking looking to be a draw
yeah I agree I mean I feel like
Dominguez can keep pushing but it's
still yeah gonna be a draw with that in
mind I think we're actually looking like
Wesley so is about to give a perpetual
check against his opponent Quezada Perez
and that one is in fact a draw by
repetition as well and so this is
looking looking a little bit dangerous
for us actually if all four of these
games and
a draw then they will need they'll need
two points to get to eight half to win
the match Lee I don't have to get to
eight to draw the match and we will have
to win at least three to one in order to
to win in that final round so I don't
know who do you think has better chances
of winning than Benjamin Bach I think I
think I like his position the most
objectively yes he does well with his
time and yeah with his time in him being
bored for this is honestly a lot of
pressure to put on the guy but I think
he's our best chance here at leveling
the score going into this final round
just on the chess board yes so of course
we can't play Knight takes T six because
rook takes d4 is an issue but maybe
there are some some creative ways to get
out of this oh well he does play Knight
takes D 664 I thought rook takes d4 was
was the idea instead we see Knight takes
d6r it takes b2 and okay after looking
one likewise I mean yeah no I think
don't see any issues White's still up
the pond and there is this rook b8
threat wait whoa whoa what's Oh what
thank you what is there what is there
shouldn't be what I don't understand
Rick c1 is threatening checkmate there's
no a perpetual check white is up simply
a queen for a rook here like it like
checkmate is threatened on the board
it's not so easy to stop Thank You
Benjamin
raise it yeah rook takes o f2 is it's
strange this is this is
strange alright well this might be what
we needed to get back into this one I
wanna watch it easy when easy when
easiest one of his life I never been an
easier chess game just to announce we do
have another results the other game was
also under than the drop dominguez does
end in a draw so that's one and a half
one and a half so far in this round and
now Benjamin Bach is looking to to level
the score for us going into the final
round simply up a queen for a rook of
course there are still tricks to it Wow
the quick Queen up three is is a nice
move from Benjamin I don't know if I
would have have I just I couldn't have
played that guarding the h1 square from
checkmate but the the speed with which
he played that move it's it's disturbing
and so now I think actually there is a
threat if I move like g4 the tempting
wait to play Queen f6 so you can play
your catch one mate I think there's
actually a fun tactic very Oh seeing in
rook c8 King age 7 rook h8 and then
there's a nice checkmate there where if
King takes h8 you have Queen takes f6
check and then forced mate on g7 so
everything working out for Bach here we
do see rook c8 and a very quick d5 so
he's guarding both of the rooks
checkmating squares using his diagonal
pieces it's it's bishop d4 miss shifty 4
to DA g1 and he does it he sees he's an
entertainer at heart I see some very
funny business here like a firework yeah
maybe it's time to stop being quite so
funny Benjamin and and just just win the
game just it's let's just call us let's
win the game say what okay so he's
promoting
okay very fancy stuff well he's
promoting he's also just playing Bishop
c5 and taking this this night off the
board okay wasn't very easier ways maybe
but I mean I'm a big fan of playing the
funniest moves in chess and I think he
he has definitely achieved that here
today should just be totally winning
Bishop e7 is nice to keep the King out
no d78 is unstoppable and a rook and a
bishop
should be enough to stop the cascade of
pawns that black still has remaining so
we see f5 but nobody seven watch it the
rook sacrifices that's all and a rook
and a bishop are enough you see a check
in another check and then we pick up g5
the king is still completely cut off and
this one is over Benjamin Bach up on
time now believe it or not
well he wins by resignation some very
fancy stuff for their to win that game
maybe you a little too fancy hurt for my
taste but he got the job done and with
that the the score is leveled six to six
coming into this final round between the
st. Louis Archbishop's and the Chicago
wind wow this is this was definitely
that one was watch games that was those
wild so with the score it completely
tied going in the final round
we need to score two and a half points
to win the match it's actually really
important that you do win the match
because you get ten bonus points added
to your score in the league standings so
8 to 8 is not enough really you need
eight and a half to make that difference
I got a card guys can do it I mean
especially in the last rounds they
usually pull true and Bobby has what I
was going to say Bobby hasn't had any
ones but he wanted to probably the one
before this one Danny that seems like
him I think he's he's got two out of
three so far yeah who was another one
did that guy I think
Dominguez has not had wins
so far all right you can be wrong as is
two drawers and a loss yeah just not
what we need for the thing is we need to
win everybody else just draw yeah well
let's recap this last round really
quickly first we of course had Fabiana
Cara wanna drawing his game against
alien is Nick money in dominguez drawing
against Ray Robson Wesley so drawing
against Quesada Perez and lastly
Benjamin Bach wins his game on board for
against Lazar over zone Batista yeah
here are the pairings for it for next
round so like you're assigning boards
one yeah
board one on board one for two against
board two and so on and so forth so who
do we need who do we need to win who do
we expect everybody yeah we for owed and
the final rounds last week let's think
we can do it again but I mean objective
oh yeah I feel like our two guys boards
of 1 & 2 Fabien linear I feel like those
would have their more objective wins
because especially because they're both
white and Fabi against Ray Robson I feel
like like the father has prepared so
much against him just because of you
guys jams and other tournaments that I
mean yeah have some history yeah I think
Lenny a really needs to step up here he
only has one point out of three so far
in this match and then I think on boards
three and four
I think Wesley is kind of our ace in the
hole here if we need him to pull through
I think Wesley is a huge favorite
against razumihin Batista and on board
for I think Benjamin Bach just needs to
keep doing what he's been doing stay
solid yeah not to give up a full point
he also played pretty solid this round
and he just paid off because his
opponents made this thing and I've been
telling everybody the chess players like
you don't always necessarily need to do
crazy stuff you can just play nice moves
nice chess and keep it solid and if your
opponent makes a mistake well perfect if
not well he deserves
I mean the the draw or the wind right
that's like yeah I don't know that's
just the mentality that seems logical
but yeah hopefully this is this is going
to pull off and our guys will win but it
was a pretty huge roller coaster yeah
this last round definitely deciding a
lot by leveling the score going into the
final round it's it's really anybody's
anybody's match
of course we are favored I think on all
four boards on this this match actually
all four of our boards are higher rated
than all four of their boards or well
their respective opponents so with four
favorable matchups hopefully we can end
up with two and a half but they've been
playing very very well so far today and
I think this this game with Benjamin
Bach that that he just won against
Batista is really the first sign of any
huge blunders and mistakes that they've
been making other than that yes it's
been very hard-fought games and they
they're very tenacious players so far
it's difficult to just score any wins
yeah yeah it's yeah I'm I just want this
is this this game just started I'm kind
of nervous yeah see how this follows up
into this building yeah this is you see
I was hoping to it'll already won like
you know some nice previous games that
we have there's like yeah we're going to
last rally we only had like half a point
sir yeah man in the first match in the
second match especially we yeah we're
we're looking pretty strong going into
this final rounds but now with a level
score these players are up against the
wall up they need to show their stuff
how are the Howard the other teams doing
in other in our division so I think
earlier today the chess bras had a
pretty crushing victory against the
Brazil capybaras and
I didn't get a chance to see what the
other scores in those matchups were but
that's the one really relevant to us
because the the Canada chess bras are of
course the only team in our division
ahead of us right now and they also only
undefeated team in the division
besides for us so we definitely want to
be keeping pace with them and we need to
score a win here today in order to do so
yeah I think it's not too far out of
reach to to go to detangle win yes
definitely we just need to get a
positive score and this final round here
and we'll be there and I think we're
almost ready to get underway
looks like HS calm people are starting
up their stream and when they they have
a library player okay we can't yeah
we're talking about a stream they can't
see but Wesley of course with that a
horrible horrible blunder in the first
round ends up losing losing a game quite
early on he has since recovered though I
think with some wins and so in this
final round we do a game starting so we
have another e4 e5 opening and we're
back on track for another Roy Lopez
Berlin oh I don't think it's gonna
Berlin i I think Dominguez has been the
big Berlin player so far this match so I
think not for them nice just the
classical Roy
let's see some of these other games I've
gotten started as well so what's going
on there looks like we have a Petrov in
one game not this game not that one
sure so this is our borderland nice you
got to do what she had to do on board
for you know Bach needs to trust in
these twenty seven hundred plus players
on boards one through three that they're
gonna be able to score some points it's
his job as board for to really just walk
away with with the draw here he's done
more than enough this match especially
winning in that last round to get us
back to a Louisville score now I needs
to be solid and to let let the
professional Wesley so Fabi Cara wanna
Lenny a dominguez team really really
show their stuff I think that's the way
for me it's not the bad way so you
actually think let's for your teammates
and then you trusted everybody else will
do their part there's there's something
comfortable about being on a team with
Fabiano Cara wanna into Wesley so and
plenty of Dominguez you know you it's a
lot less pressure on you especially when
you've already scored such such a key
win at that Benjamin Barker that's
pretty nice one on this week um let's
take a look at this list game it's also
not the fencer if you know this one
seems to be boring I'm bored what's
going on here barreling would be the
boring one yeah this this one this will
no also not super interesting to my eyes
but yeah Wesley plays c5 he's trying to
break down this Center expect wait to
play a move like 'if or in the future I
think this is something he's he's aiming
for and it looks like Wes who's gonna
bring his Bishop out onto the long
diagonal ins as well to challenge this
Eve Foursquare yeah yeah look let's go
for the petrol fun cuz this is I feel
like it maybe we should go
time moves before something interesting
is going
I agree but this Petroff game let me
tell you I think this is one that's
that's gonna shape up to be a little bit
more interesting with opposite sides
castling and Dominguez looking to attack
the Kings side take a pump
take with the pawn fix the structure or
take with the Queen I'll take with the
pawn your queen we can come to g2 it
would be such a nice Queen g2 but now
this Queen a big fan of this Queen G
two's yeah without the pawn on e3
there's just a little bit more space for
this Queen to move around and the pawn
on the e3 might also become kind of a
weakness I think that the recommend a so
here we have a very interesting position
where the sides or the Kings are on
opposite sides but also the bishops are
on opposite colors which is kind of a
key feature of attacking positions when
you have these opposite colored bishops
it's very important to have the safer
King and I think in this case white is
going to have have that safer King and
with the abundance of F pawns that white
has can imagine a move like Queenie for
forces a move like g6 then we can start
pushing these F pawns to really break
down the light squares around the King
and I think that's the way forward for
Dominguez here so play move like Queenie
for play move like f4 and then afters
things like f5 you can start trying to
to attack the King with more devastating
effect yeah but instead of Queen
efore maybe something like already f4
yeah I like maybe starting with f4 or
even starting with with h4 if you can
get away with it I don't know if maybe I
if you capture that punic there might be
Bishop h7 it is yeah like just three
four and you're gonna bring the other I
shouldn't yeah we should I work I so I
like moves like f4 and and h4 actually
and then eventually I think black is is
going to play the move cheese sticks and
we'll have that hook that we need to
latch on to start opening up lines so I
think this one looks rather promising
for for Dominguez
uh who else do you want to take a look
at Bobby sure we can look at fabi's game
it's it's another Roy Lopez as we were
talking about and this one looks just as
complicated as all the other royal a
peasant's that I've ever seen in my life
so g3 from Fabi keeps an eye on the f4
square can also play a move like King G
too soon to unpin this F pawn and with
the black pawns in the center I don't
know how do you move your pieces here
I'm not super familiar I think sometime
I can gauge to be reasonable it seems
like White's pieces are kind of stepping
on each other's toes yeah we organized
yeah because you can't do something like
t4 and you need something like d4 to
open up so that's why I was trying to
like do something like v4 first or
something like f4 some some stuff like
that just to open more room for
breathing okay and then you could follow
it ideally by something like before like
let's say King is to f4 and like you
want to play something like d4 yeah yeah
I guess I take the point but it feels
weird to be playing f4 while your pieces
are still kind of jumbled up like this I
don't think he's quite ready to break
through in that specific manner but I
was thinking maybe you could just bring
this night to to f3 maybe over to h2 and
then after you've done that I think I
like f4 a lot more in that specific case
the knight on h2 looks a little bit
weird but I think it's a lot better than
the D 2 square where it's blocking off
all of the white pieces yeah also I just
like to point out like the time
difference
yeah Bobby of course moving very very
quickly and Ray having himself a bit of
a think here about what to do
definitely that's that's one reason to
prefer prefer the white pieces here even
just simply the clocks and yeah rook f7
is is his choice simply King G to
getting the King to a better Square and
now Ray's gonna pick up the pace a
little bit he I think it's decided on
this next few moves kind of a plan of
action here so Queen d7 I think is
telegraphing Rick a to f8 is probably
next on the agenda and Ray is going to
look to use this open F file to put some
pressure on on this White King side what
about something like f4 not if it takes
them d4 I really don't like playing f4
in in this type of position where my
Knights stuck on d2 and we get to play
f4 take d4 you move the bishop and I
play e5 you gotta love the Knights yeah
yeah it just seems so loose to do to do
this with no pieces around my king but
that's the beauty of it okay all right
instead we see Knight b3 I'm hitting
this Bishop and note we need to it was a
little too magical to actually work it's
just it's so scary yeah I don't like
being scared Bishop e3 and so now this C
v square is looking a little bit tender
bobbies kind of daring right to play
this move d4 and I'm not sure if it's
any good or not
d 4i I guess we're planning to capture
that pawn I don't know maybe not maybe
simply Bishop t2 okay this game
certainly has a lot of chests left to be
played but maybe there could be a nice
c5 going up yeah I was saying the c5
score looks a little tender but I was
yeah I was thinking d4 for black
immediately is what Fabia is kind of
daring here and I wasn't sure how the
other thing that I was thinking too
something like even a 4/4 white so you
start trying to open up that side right
yeah I think a 4 it makes makes a lot of
sense
so we've seen night h7 from black opens
up the rooks along this F file and now
it's fabi's turn to kind of make a
decision what does he want to do so we
see Bishop c5 and I like this move a lot
so no d4 never comes with tempo you
never really want to capture this Bishop
because then the knight comes to c5 and
it just makes black the blacks piece it
makes the black pieces look a little bit
awkward especially with this rook on f8
yes I agree I'm only thinking well so if
you're not want to take it how can you
continue are you gonna play something
like an IV 7 so 48 assist race I don't
think black really wanted to take it all
cuz night and I don't see 5 hits the
Queen on g7 and hits the pawn on a6 it
hits the opponent east 6 and then maybe
your move a4 could could come with a lot
more a lot more oomph in coordination
with this knight on c5 I have to ask
Luke no power like yeah like power now
is a good spot you know feeling alright
oxi thank you yeah winds on the board
yeah yeah I like this move a lot it does
break down the Queen side pretty
effective yeah a 4 is just such a such a
really Lopez move okay up to you who do
you want to see oh let's take another
look at the ming Gaza's game this one i
think is is progressing Wow
I think it went oh pretty similar to the
lines we were talking about where black
did end up playing g6 white went ahead
with h4 h5 and started breaking down
these light squares using that pawn
hunter and now I expect to see move like
f5 coming pretty quickly from white to
take away these final defenders around
the black King and I think it's a very
natural plan that Dominguez has followed
in it I think it's executed it well huh
and also he's not I mean he's still
pretty down on time but it's not half
right but yeah I was gonna mention this
this move from black I think is very
really important and I think it's it's
pretty good for him actually so I think
the idea is if white wants to continue
very naturally with the move like f5 now
he's gonna get hit with c4 and this
bishops gonna have to leave this
diagonal from d3 to h7 and I think if
the bishop can't stand this diagonal up
and these what these threats to the
light squares become a lot less potent
so I'm not sure what Dominguez is
planning to do about it
of course can't play see for yourself
otherwise Queen takes b2 happens yeah
and so he needs some way to to kind of
prevents this Bishop from being removed
but I'm not sure such a way exists I'm
not sure if this I was gonna say that's
a stinging look I'm not sure if that's
five work so that's yeah and I was so
this is this is pretty blatantly
sacrificing a piece right after c4 I
mean you're not planning to move the
bishop you're planning to take g6 that
c4 it takes g6 takes d3 it takes f7 well
maybe instead of taking a seven you can
play queen r7 King okay
bridge between I still don't see you I
mean so yeah you can play taking on f7
but Queen f7 and how do you know
so Dominguez wastes no time see how Z
he's sacking this Bishop let's see what
the follow-up is for him I think I like
just taking the pawn on f7 he agrees
probably king f7 I think and then maybe
just to move like Rick d3
this is a small way rook to e3 there's
there's queen h6 check to trade the
Queen yes Queen it's five check G AIDS
then you take your debates then Queen d5
baby yeah I think I like Queen Queen d5
I think this is this is this idea check
okay
I mean you have to give a check here I
don't think wooden c7 is is going to get
the job done simply Ricky seven and then
you clean again it's like Queen h5
should be it just looking here maybe
maybe f4 is is the other move being
consumed ah you're blocking Queen six
check yes and that's also you would be
because what if something like f4 and I
wasn't a rookie - Ricky - um maybe then
then a queen h5 could come tea tree
yeah that's actually well cleaner for
it's difficult it's difficult I'm not so
sure this piece sacrifice was what we
needed from from Dominguez here
especially now that he's after the
sacrifice he's spending all his time
that that's never good to see so maybe
there was something he's seeing now that
he doesn't quite like whatever to play
some more moves how is Wesley so doing
huh hmm I think this is actually pretty
I think this one is looking a-ok for the
Grandmaster with a cat avatar yes see
four oh wow this is asking some
questions I I'm I'm thinking this with
most likely I mean it's really depends
how it perceives but if you do manage to
get like the eighth floor and see three
both of them right you need should be
good enough to you know get some stuff
done it's a play for a win you mean yeah
I kind of agree that the question is can
black keep enough pawns on the board
well he's trying to run around and and
capture all of these these white pawns
to really keep winning chances alive and
I think that's gonna be the tough part
here so of course there's moves like
Rick takes a four to consider things
like Knight e4 check and they take c3 or
also on the cards but black will have to
try to do all this without letting the
white rooks get too active on the
seventh rank and without giving up
really I think if you give up the a5
pawn it becomes a lot more difficult to
win yeah I agree so something like 55
maybe so 94 Kingi too weak a for
something like that would be yeah this
that seems like a reasonable way to go
and then there's ideas of playing route
b7 check and in Knight g5
could cause some problems for for black
actually but that being said it's kind
of double-edged sword also babe so let
me see where it takes c3 what if just
like Brooke be fine if I think baby
Knight e4 could be blacks idea
I think after Knight e4 you are making
some pretty serious threats of
checkmating that white King yeah I just
like to point that that's that's eight
seconds this this time is really really
really scary especially when you're pawn
has like minutes Wow
so yeah I think we should stay on this
Bobby eight seconds to five minutes is a
lot and and Fabi seems to be going after
after this Kang once again so what's
going on here how can we how can we kill
him
I think Queen age 7 does does the job
the idea is Bishop g6 and then you're
just checkmated
I don't really see how to stop maybe I
think Queen age 7 you have to play Queen
g8 it's that maybe maybe 97 actually I
don't know 97 97 doesn't feel right it
feels like something should should be
wrong there this is just me guessing
anyways I think there should be played
and then you just slept up on us figure
out where to go yeah uh all right I'm
gonna cheat now nice yeah Queen Queen h7
was +2
this move is only like +1 but now I mean
obviously black isn't going to be
playing very accurately either
apparently the best move by far is rook
f2 never would have guessed but Bobby is
doing doing quite quite well here this
one should be good for us it looks like
though I will say there's time pressure
in a couple other games very notably
Benjamin Bach is down to his final 20
seconds and stop staring at this game
yeah alright let's move to another game
okay
so Benjamin Bach down to 20 seconds in
this position looks pressured but I
don't know I don't think this is
actually yeah not not the easiest
position actually for for Benjamin here
say we see 94 and I think the big
problem here is white can play c3 to
remove this knight from deep form but
the black is going to struggle to play
the move c6 yeah due to this pressure of
the pawn on on b5 so yeah there we do
actually see c3 come into play and maybe
black will try to remove this night with
something like Knight f4 here I think I
like this move Knight f4 to really try
and get rid of this night before it's a
problem Benjamin Bach disagrees though
not a lot of time to think about it it's
simply Rick df7
huh so if Esther kept Sun he would have
played King g8 he would be repeats Oh
Bobby won Bobby won nice so we were
expecting this so that brings as the
plus was yeah we just need three drawers
and and the round is ours the round and
the match I am a little worried about
this game on a sleeve blend the name
Gary well I have some great news we
should check back in on Wesley Zoe's
game because things have gone well for
him remember that pawn in a fire we said
he needed to keep to have winning
chances upon an a5 is now on a two baby
Queen well that's the kind of a queen
it's it's it's a middle aged Queen
honest young adults nearing nearing full
Queen them on a two it's gonna come to a
1 and that'll be six five six surely you
can Queen here right
oh that King runs to b8 and there's no
more checks so you you clean Ricky seven
check King d8 Knight f7 check King c8
wait a second no my phone got painted no
I think that's a draw a few Queen you
right oh well night of seven check I
have no that's a dry see 896 15 be a
it's rip p7 bye-bye yeah
so don't Queen here Wesley cuz that
would be bad I think door
yeah 94 should should get the job done
cuz I heard 79 of seven can see it night
there is no number 96 right sixes is
covered I mean if you wanna be mean
maybe 95 works she can I be by a bad
choice Wesley really taking his time
here I'm sure he sees the threat of
Ricky seven and he's just finding making
sure the move like 94 move like Knight
b5 really gets the job done
yeah I mean he does play nicely earn 84
now and now he will be queening with
little little complications
Queen Queen there it is alright and now
they're hooking the Queen together we'll
check me at the White King before the
pawn on f7 can even dream of being more
montre official so y'all so what's the
win system
Benjamin draws his game bringing us to
the required eight and a half points
Archbishop's are the winners nothing
this last game doesn't matter well it
doesn't matter but we want everyone
we already won't matter and the team
results I guess correct eight and a half
is enough to win the match and those top
two boards really getting it done and
Benjamin Bach a superb board for drawing
his match brings us dominguez just got
checkmated in reckon bishop against rook
yeah but it doesn't matter we win eight
and a half to seven 1/2 Archbishop's yes
are the winners of this match they get
those 10 extra points for winning the
match added to their total score in the
division we're pretty good scared
yeah this this was by far the closest
match of the year so far and Chicago the
Chicago wind really putting some
pressure on the Archbishop's here we
were we were behind up until this final
round here when well it was it was
suspenseful to be sure definitely some
excitement it was oh well all that
matters is we won 18 and a half percent
oh yeah yeah so be sure to join us next
week I don't are you gonna be here next
week still undecided possibly join us
next week definitely join me next week
when we're going to be covering week
four I believe our next opponent is the
California unicorns a tough opponent to
be sure but I think I like the
archbishop chances against anybody in
the lead yes
yeah me too I mean we got Bobby we got
worse for you
the Mingus we have so many players yeah
I don't know
yeah I think by far we're always gonna
have the highest average rating no
matter who we're up against yeah this
this is this was some very good wrap-up
oh very nice to see we win yes so
congratulations to this Archbishop's
team winning winning the match yet
congratulations to you as well Doris I
suppose winning the match eight and a
half to seven and a half and I guess
that's it for us today thank you so much
for joining us and we will see you we
will see you next week this has been a
presentation of the st. Louis chess club
you